time for pft on yahoo sports chris sims
in for peter king mike florio in for
mike florio here to talk about some of
the big story lines in the nfl and one
of the big story lines
occurred on sunday as it relates to one
of the worst teams the jaguars
congratulations they have clinched
the number one overall pick in the draft
which means trevor lawrence will be on
his way from clemson
to jacksonville what do you believe
that will mean for this franchise and
for lawrence
assuming he does indeed enter the draft
and does become
the pick of the jaguars and does become
the first real potential franchise
quarterback chris they've had since
mark brunell yeah right well i mean it's
one of those that
energizes a fan base energizes a whole
region of a country really when you have
a guy like trevor lawrence who's been
dominant from the get-go you know taking
over for the clemson football team in a
year where
whoa wait they're a national
championship team and he's a freshman
and he's going to play alabama and tua
in the national championship game and
wait what they blew them out and
dominated them
i mean that's the way his career has
been he's a sp
you could tell first off you know he is
the type of human being
and guy you want to stand in front of
the podium
to be the franchise quarterback i've
never seen him not answer questions and
act the
appropriate way and then on the football
field mike
you know let me ask you this because
this is who i compare him to
what do you think of justin herbert this
year you think he's pretty good
justin herbert's pretty good yeah right
well that's what trevor lawrence to me
is it's justin herbert it's that type of
football player
except maybe with a little bit more of a
play-making ability
and been on the big stage of college
football more to where
he relishes that even more than you know
the questions we had there so that's
what you should be excited about
jacksonville a superstar
who could lead your franchise to a lot
of playoff games for years and years to
come
he's also got that ryan tannehill pedal
to the metal shot out of a cannon when
it's time to run
it's not zigging and zagging it's not
running to the sideline
it's just i see an opening and i'm gone
right and uh so i i think that uh
i think that lawrence is going to be
great i i don't know whether the jaguars
can capital there's just something about
the jaguars until they can prove it they
got so close three years ago
they had the afc championship game in
hand and they had all those great young
players and now they've got all the cap
space and all the draft picks to try to
rebuild it that's going to be the
challenge
this is going to be a great general
manager job but it's also going to be a
ton of responsibility because there will
be no excuses
you will be expected to turn this team
into a contender
right away and they also have to decide
what they're going to do with the head
coach
you know maybe doug marone gets one more
year with the new gm i don't know
shot khan seems like a guy who is
reluctant to fire people
maybe marone by participating in the
tanking for trevor lawrence has earned a
year with trevor lawrence
maybe they got some talent on the
offense dj chark leviska chanal
you know the running back robinson
there's some stuff to be excited about
there
and you talked about his running hey
just remember last year the final four
the guy ran for like a 50-yard touchdown
on ohio state ohio state's got guys that
run 4-3
all over their football team so that
just tells you what type of specimen he
is
well he's going to be a jacksonville
jaguar and that should make jaguars fans
extremely happy and it also should make
our friends
in the uk very happy because the jaguars
play it right one game per year
over there they were going to play two
this year but for the pandemic so
they're going to get to know trevor
lawrence
very well too assuming he doesn't return
to clemson and he shouldn't
and assuming that the jaguars take him
first overall and
they should thanks for some of your time
we'll see you next time for more pft on
yahoo
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports